to understand what factors of
polynomials are and how they can be used
we need to understand the basics of
factorization first we start with simple
numbers how do we find the factors of
the number six to find the factors of
six ask yourself how can we write 6 as a
product of two numbers we can write 6 as
one multiplied by 6 and also 2
multiplied by 3 is there any other
combination you can think of no there
isn't any so the factors of 6 are these
four numbers 1 2 3 & 6 1 is a factor of
6 since there is some natural number
that it can be multiplied with to get
the original number similarly 2 3 & 6
are also factors but the number four is
not a factor of 6 because it cannot be
multiplied with a natural number to get
a 6 let us also try finding factors for
the number 8 8 can be written as 1
multiplied by 8 and 2 x 4 there is no
other combination of the two numbers
which gives us 8 so the factors of 8 are
1 2 4 & 8 this can also be seen in a
different way if we divide a number by
any of its factors the remainder will
always be 0 if you divide 6 by 3 you
will get 2 as the quotient if you divide
6 by 1 you will get 6 as the quotient if
you divide 8 by 2 you will get 4 as the
quotient in all the cases the remainder
is 0 how does this help us what if we
want to know whether a number is a
factor of another number or not for
example if we want to know whether it is
a factor of 216 what would you do this
is where division helps us if you want
to know whether 8
is a factor of 216 all we need to do is
divide 216 by 8 after the division if we
get the remainder as 0 we can say that 8
is a factor of 216 so let us divide 216
by 8 yes the traditional way where we
write 216 like this and 8 next to it
after solving we get the quotient as 27
and the remainder as 0 as the remainder
is 0 we can say that 8 is a factor of
216 we can write 216 as 8 multiplied by
27 what else can we say after looking at
this process is 27 a factor of 216 yes
as we can write 216 as 8 x 27 27 is also
a factor of 216 remember 8 and 27 are
two of the many factors of 216 this
division just helps us to know if 8 is a
factor of 216 or not and if we find out
that the divisor is a factor then the
quotient as well has to be a factor
let's see if 9 is a factor of 216 we
will have to divide two hundred and
sixteen by nine so after we finish our
division process we see that the
remainder is zero so 9 is a factor of
216 and since 216 can also be written as
9 x 24 24 is also a factor of 216 in the
process of finding out if 8 and 9 are
factors of 216 we also found out two
more factors of 216 27 and 24 what about
10 is it a factor of 216 to find out we
divide 216 by 10
in this case we get the remainder as six
as it's not zero we can say that 10 is
not a factor of 216 we can also conclude
that 21 is not a factor of 216 remember
if the remainder is zero the divisor and
the quotient are both factors of the
dividend
you